all right today's topic dave chappelle
and this netflix debacle so there's been
a lot of backlash in regards to special
he's made references to trans people
some people feel like it's hateful et
cetera et cetera and um there's been a
lot of interesting responses joey
soloway the creator of the amazon series
transparent saying this is gender
violence sharing his outrage as comedic
humiliation in front of thousands of
people and then broadcasting it to
hundreds of millions of people is
infinitely amplified gender violence i
want trans representation on the netflix
board a trans person on the effing
netflix board this [ __ ] week okay and
you can hear this a lot people are
feeling like what dave chappelle said is
violence
okay
and i don't know how to tell you guys
this in any simpler terms
but at no way shape or form are words
violence
they never have been they never will be
unless someone threatens you with
violence which is illegal
it's not violence
words are never going to be violence
well abba what he says leads to physical
harm sure maybe maybe you can make that
case a lot of things lead to physical
harm
in terms of words maybe you gossip about
somebody that could lead to physical
harm maybe you give somebody too much
stress when you yell at them that could
lead to physical harm a lot of words
could lead to like induced stress and
things like that but that's not the same
as violence words have meanings
and when you change that to suit
whatever narrative you want
it has real world implications
when you tell people that their opinions
are violence
you are inherently justifying a violent
reaction that's why you have goobers
like antifa who think it's perfectly
acceptable to show up to places and beat
them there why because their ideas are
violent we're devolving into a weird
society where we're saying oh if you
don't say what i like that's violence
excuse me are you saying i assaulted you
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what is that what does that even mean
words are violent behaving or involving
physical force intended to hurt damage
or kill someone or something you know
even if we grant you that what he's
saying is hateful he's gonna grant you
that what if we grant it which i don't i
do not believe it's hateful but you're
entitled to view it however it's
subjective in that sense okay if you
feel that way it still doesn't qualify
as violence he was violent towards me
what happened how did he hit you no he
said a bunch of things that were
terrible that's not violence i'm sorry
okay all right
you said a bunch of things
terrible exactly and then they have
another line which i think is crazy
which is silence is violence
i heard that a lot
silence is violence so
if you say what i don't like you're
being violent if you don't speak you're
being violent at some point you're gonna
get to a point where it's like either
say exactly what i said or it's violence
and this is how they're co-opting folks
into thinking exactly what they want you
cannot not speak on an issue
right if you're not speaking on that
issue you're being violent you're being
violent or
you're encouraging the oppression
this language is look at this this lady
was just eating food
during the black lives matter stuff
right this lady was just eating at a
restaurant and because she wasn't out
there protesting they surrounded her out
of the restaurant she was on the terrace
and they're like white silence is
violence it's like what and i've heard
that a lot
i've heard that a lot every time there's
a tragedy well you remember when it
happened when when the the black hat
happened the black hat happened and
there's a bunch of people that were not
posting that black square
and then and what by the way the blows
in the black square was a blackout so
that more black voices would be heard
but what it did was you just see black
squared and
all the black forces were submerged but
i digress when people were not posting
that black square
they were they went in the dm i know i
know what happened in the dance
community why aren't you not there's
some people in the dance community came
after the of the people why aren't you
not
posting the black square yeah because it
you can't not want to be involved in
something
you can't not be knowledgeable about
something and feel uninformed you can't
be unsure about anything if you don't
speak you're engaging in violence think
about the implications of that
you're engaging in violence just like
you know they don't even take into
consideration sometimes a [ __ ]
is just tired
well if you're tired you're being
violent [ __ ] what
you know i don't want to hear about
every tragedy that happens over the
world abba how come you haven't spoken
about palestine i don't know i'm not i
don't want to be informed that's
violence what are you smoking meanwhile
those what are you smoking meanwhile
those people are not posting anything
about haiti they're not supposing about
nothing by chile about colombia about
none of this are you being violent
because you haven't spoken about it soon
it's going to be ignorance's violence
being unaware is violence and and where
when when yeah then you're moving you
know you're wearing no socks yeah being
violent right now oh these people are
weird we're socks
are violent yes they are they're not
pretty they're violent bass violence
being ugly is violent god damn i've had
a violent reaction bruh and and i think
why this is important this conversation
is that when we look at a stand-up
comedian doing jokes right jokes that we
may not agree with are telling a story
from a perspective we don't like we
don't write a engage anything with words
anymore it's
they literally try to cancel they said
get them de-platformed
take the money and give it to trans
creators right uh take the money and put
it into trans causes make sure that
there's a disclaimer saying this is
transphobia according to who
according to who because you think so
what if there's other trans people who
don't who are you to label this because
think about it if they get you to accept
that words are violence then yeah
there's a justification for stopping
jake chappelle that's a real
justification he's being violent on
stage violence is unacceptable in
society
so if you can convince everyone that
what he said his words or violence
then you can get people to believe
anything that no matter what you say no
matter what you say and anybody says it
if you can deem it violent you can
cancel it imagine this imagine you go
out and you say hey
this person is ugly
i don't think they're attractive at all
that's violence
and that person dies because someone
killed them
you because you said that on the
public platform you are participating in
their murder
why because your words linked to that it
caused physical they'll make leaps and
bounds that you won't believe and you
might be thinking oh abba you're being
hyperbolic did you ever think we'd get
to a point where words became violence
because i certainly didn't think that 15
20 years ago
did you
am i crazy
no you're violent did you think we would
get to a point
where
when a criminal enters a female change
room
a male criminal
enters a female change room when the
females say that they feel unsafe in
that change room that's violence they
are tacked
and everyone said the females were being
violent for not wanting that trans man
that trans woman who who was a criminal
into their change room
an offender
did you ever think we get to this point
understand the goalports keep moving
right they're talking about netflix you
need to hire a director who's trained
a vp who's trans
say why
now they're trying to tell companies how
to run their [ __ ] who they can or can't
hire this [ __ ] has gone mad
they're trying to create the
untouchables and that you can't mention
us you can't talk about us in a
derogatory way you can't talk about us
in a comedic way you can't make fun of
us it's like guys
in comedy it's a simple rule it's either
all okay or not okay
that's how it works you can't put these
arbitrary lines like trans people are
dying so you can't make jokes listen
every [ __ ] out here dying okay
you don't get a special privilege in
regards to what humor is or isn't
acceptable you can choose to not watch
something you can critique the special
you can say the special was trash you
could even say that special had some
hate in it that's fine i'm not mad at
that when you try to cancel people when
you try to label what they're saying as
violence even though it's not right
because violence is criminal
sorry guys being violent is criminal i
got an issue with that
people are changing all the definition
of every word and then we're all just
supposed to sit by and watch it when the
whole silence is violence then people
are like oh yeah if you don't speak
people get hurt so no that's not the way
it works
inaction is not an action that's not
that's not how it works
is this no it's not though
that's not
not speaking is speaking no it's not
maybe i'm gathering my thoughts maybe i
have nothing to say you said everything
with your silence can you stop can you
stop walking around the room
i mean you're not walking but you're
walking by now
rough stop and by changing the words and
have everyone accepted that is how they
co-opt the power structures that is how
they make those changes that they want
yes well you can change from female to
male no [ __ ] you can't
you want to change your gender male to
woman to man i don't care but you can't
change sexes it's just you can't change
definitions and it reminded me of what
happened to
my good friend
and mentor mike
it's what's happening with him
so what happened with him it's basically
someone making a comedy set
try to prove a point how you can't
touch certain people
not physically i'm talking about you
can't talk about certain people a
certain way and he talked about
handicapped kids he talked he talked
about all the people that were
untouchable so he spoke about celine
dion he told celebrities celebrities and
different people that you cannot talk
about in quebec and you talk about an
endicott kid how you cannot talk to him
about him yeah and the people
proved
his point they sued him right
he's right now waiting for
his
supreme court yeah if he doesn't pay the
fine he goes to jail yes sir yeah yeah
yeah so supreme this is similar to that
to me it's similar to that because she
did a bit
trying to expose something how yo you're
canceling us you're doing that [ __ ] that
you don't want to be done to you yeah
but you're doing that and then people
turn around and prove his point
no cancel them take down this special
and stuff like that so that's a bit the
same point that that that that happened
to mike and he's being sued right now
mike what i'm talking about mike why
basically and he's being sued right now
in supreme it went to supreme court
silence is not violence okay words are
not violence
they never will be and don't let anybody
convince you otherwise
don't let anyone convince you otherwise
you can say those things are wrong but
they're not violence and i think that's
what the crux of this is people are
trying to say they don't want to see the
world as it is they want to see the
world as they see it and that matters
because then they can just pull you into
their imagination and have you believe
in things that aren't real that's why
you go on college campuses everybody got
to walk on eggshells why because they've
co-opted that structure do you want to
join a performer in the college proof
remember when we went to that remember
when we went to that university to do a
show and i was just and i was and i was
and i was and i was hosting and i went
to ask someone so hey hey how you doing
yeah what's the name
and i got met with and you were back on
the side and i got met with a you don't
have my consent to ask me my name
and i just went oh boy and i just went
with the show and you started laughing
because how ridiculous that was that's
why we don't do shows on campus that's
why we don't do shows on campus no more
we don't do comedy on campus no and
we're not the only one a lot of
comedians this voice their opinion about
we're not doing shows on university
campuses or college campuses because
100 these people are trying to censor
folks they're trying to censor folks
they're trying to have it in the back
your head that there's going to be
tremendous consequences if you make
jokes about trans people basically
making themselves a a very special class
that you can't even mock what are you
smoking you're not special you're not
different okay you get joked about like
everybody else why
for what reason and listen guys
it's important to confront ideas you
don't like to be met with speech you
don't enjoy you want to know why because
it makes you more resilient
yes
and retaliating with violence
is a basic human
reaction and it's not something you
should give into that's what savages and
uncivilized people do just because
someone says something you want to get
violent their words are violent no
there's no substitute for violence
okay
some of you need to build like thick
skin
y'all out here talking about i'm gonna
snuff somebody if they say something
what's wrong with you
what
not anyway
this is why i kept thinking about
silence and violence i was like [ __ ]
i'm tired i don't want to watch the news
and [ __ ] comment on some [ __ ] hey
silence is violence but there's some
people you know
you know there's some people that do
threaten you there's some people that
use their words and then you know
they challenge you to a boxing match
yeah
and then you say yes
where i'm gonna go there
i like how you said you don't want to
bring that [ __ ] up and then you brought
that [ __ ] i didn't i didn't mention no
name anyways listen i said i don't want
to mention their names let us know what
you guys think in the comments
i thought i knew one of mentional names
i don't want to mention no names